This is really something else as as we've
been covering a Joe Biden has been doing a
lot as president elect Donald Trump as president,
hasn't been doing a damn thing for months
now.
Many of his allies have abandoned him.
West Palm Beach doesn't seem to want him down
there in New York City, certainly doesn't
want him or his kids.
It's just sort of a sad denouement for Donald
Trump.
But Trump has found some unwavering support
in some elements of right wing media, including
on Newsmax and still in some places on Fox
News, the more sycophantic ones anyway.
So later we're going to do a deep dove into
a particular Fox News interview that went
comically haywire.
But I want to give you a sampling of the clips
that Donald Trump has been retweeting and
amplifying.
And the takeaway here for me is that the next
four years are going to be insane.
That's that's my takeaway.
We'll see if you come away with the same notion
FOX News was nuts during Barack Obama's presidency.
But Fox News competing with CNN, Newsmax for
the same audience is likely to lead to a sort
of one upmanship contest for who can come
up with the most wacky anti Biden conspiracy
theories and false reports.
So let's dove right in.
In the first clip retweeted by Donald Trump,
there was a panel on the show, The Five, about
Trump being admired in 2020.
And one of the five people figures out a way
to delusional, brownnose Donald Trump.
Trump loved it and retweeted it.
Take a look.
Well, see, I think President Trump, interestingly,
stands at the top because he has been an incredible
president.
He has, though, Maria.
He is someone who led one of the strongest
economies we saw pre covid.
This is a man who has gone to more Middle
East peace deals done in just one term alone.
He's gotten more than half of the all the
peace deals we have seen in our nation's history
done done in one term.
This is someone who got Mexico to step up
to the plate on things like illegal immigration.
This is someone who has brought a business
approach.
To Washington, D.C., therefore, solving problems
when people like Joe Biden, who have been
there forever, created the mess that President
Trump went to go fix.
And I also think it's remarkable because you
have the media who is vilified him, demonized
him, lied about him, and yet he still sits
atop the throne.
And Maria, I love you, but this must be a
hard segment for me.
So just to pick one thing, because there's
so much nonsense here, she said half of all
peace deals in the nation's history were done
by Donald Trump during his first term.
OK, that didn't ring true to me, so I decided
I would fact check it.
Now, some of these so-called deals Trump got
done were not even really peace deals.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
But if you go back to the Treaty of Tripoli
in 1835, there are 11 of what we would call
overtly peace deals.
And then there are way more that aren't called
peace deals, but effectively are peace deals
to some degree.
She says Trump did more peace deals in one
term than were previously done in all of American
history.
That is very much false.
But the real issue is that the deals Trump
did are really mirage's.
Trump did a deal with the UAE and Israel.
Those countries had already agreed to engage
independent of Trump, and they weren't in
what we would call a conflict to begin with,
Bahrain and Israel, same thing.
And then, of course, Trump's promise on Israeli-Palestinian
peace with Jared Kushner was going to figure
out for us silence.
No progress at all.
Another clip.
These are clips retweeted by Trump sucking
up to him.
This is from on a totally made up story fabricated
out of thin air about military ballot tampering.
Trump loves it.
He retweeted it.
While new investigations reveal military ballots
were major targets of Democrat voter fraud
in November, reports on Thursday note thousands
of military ballots were potentially tampered
with at polling stations during the general
election.
This after several witnesses came forward
during a hearing in Georgia Wednesday with
both photo and video evidence of rampant fraud.
Republican poll watchers also claim they got
locked out of the counting stations when it
came to look time to look over military ballots,
which typically lean red.
So that's absolutely nuts.
Not a single court has found any merit to
any of the claims you just heard.
Trump doesn't care.
He loves it.
He tweets it.
Next clip also from on, which presents a battle
for the White House battle.
The election's over, Biden won, Trump lost,
doesn't matter, Trump loves it.
This one is made even funnier because the
anchor is struggling to deliver the scripted
agit trash like she's she's struggling to
even read this nonsense off of the prompter.
The battle continues for the White House as
President Trump and his legal team continue
to reveal and investigate the irregularities
of the 2012 election.
President Trump has several avenues to secure
his second term.
Primarily, the state legislatures have the
constitutional authority and responsibility
to select the correct electors for their respective
states.
Seven states had both sets of electors vote
on December 14th.
Pennsylvania, Georgia, Michigan, Wisconsin,
Arizona, Nevada and New Mexico all had Republican
electors cast their votes as well as the Democrat
electors.
Currently, all seven of the state secretaries
of state have sent the Democrat electors to
be counted.
The state legislatures have the constitutional
responsibility to ensure that the electors
sent from their state are correct.
So that's a complete fantasy.
None of that is going on.
And then one more here may be the nuttiest
one and only one reporter named Pearson Sharp
stands in front of a blackboard reminiscent
of Glenn Beck's old conspiracy show, a bunch
of stuff written in chalk outlining a completely
farcical understanding of how elections work.
This is a five minute clip.
I'm not going to torture you like that.
I'll just play 40 seconds for you to give
you a sense of it.
The so-called election results on November
3rd are puzzling to a lot of people, at least.
Seventy five million, but probably a lot more.
That's because up until that point, all signs
were that President Trump was set to win a
historic victory over Joe Biden.
And many still believe that's exactly what
happened.
Even if the alleged vote counts, tell a different
story.
Despite what the mainstream media has declared,
President Trump was projected to win because
he had ushered in an unprecedented era of
prosperity for Americans from all walks of
life.
At the start of twenty twenty before the Chinese
pandemic and Democratic governors devastated
our nation.
American optimism about the economy was at
an all time high.
That guy has never seen a point he will actually
make, just droning on and on with circumstantial
conjecture.
But his point is Trump won and Trump liked
it.
So Trump retweeted that video.
These are the things where if you even see
a reputable reporter re tweet this, you say,
wow, that's a concern.
The president of the United States is retweeting
this stuff.
We'll have more coverage of this on our Instagram
page.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show and follow me on Instagram for
pictures from my vacation warning.
They are very boring.
I'm David Pakman on Instagram,